Hello and welcome to the Udacity
course on Prototyping.
In this course we'll be covering te
fundamentals of making prototypes to
quickly and
effectively make choices about your app.
This is a vital skill for
entrepreneurs, project managers, and
anyone else who wants to build
an experience that will delight users.
My name is Jay.
I'm a Udacity instructor, and
I'll be guiding you through the
practical application of these skills.
Later parts of the course
will also feature Carl,
a UX engineer at Google, and
Johnathan, an Envision specialist.
They will be helping you with
the details of user research and
medium to high fidelity prototyping.
The art of prototyping mainly
exists to make your apps better and
to save you time and
money in building products.
You like having more time and money?
You should be prototyping.
Let's get started.